wir haben uns schon mit verschiedenen
Budgets durch den Tag geschlagen zum
einen mit 1 € mit 5 € mit 10 € mit 20 €
und heute 50 € für einen Tag eine ganze
Menge wenn man sich diesen Schein hier
so anschaut deshalb bin ich gespannt was
wir alles köstliches genießen können an
diesem Tag ich bin mir sicher es wird
richtig richtig lecker und das ist
wirklich schon eine gute Stange Geld mit
der wir unser Tag gestalten können
deshalb gucken wir erstmal was wir uns
zum Frühstücken los geht's viel Spaß mit
dem Video
es ist Zeit einzukaufen und zwar für
unser Frühstück mit 50 € werden wir
einiges machen können und ich bin mir
sicher dass ihr es genau der richtige
Ort Mara Atlantico ein Delikatessenladen
mediterrane Feinkost let's go schauen
wir mal was wir mit dem Geld anstellen
können
[Musik]
so Freunde hier ist unsere Ausbeute ich
finde sie kann sich wirklich sehen
lassen im Herzen von dem ganzen steht
dieses Focaccia drück mal drauf es
erhebt sich wieder sehr sehr schön sehr
sehr edel dazu haben wir hier kommt euch
vielleicht bekannt vor wenn ihr das MR
Wissen to go Video gesehen habt
porquetra die Königin unter den
aufschnitten wir haben wir haben Rucola
wir haben Tomaten wir haben
Büffelmozzarella und wir beginnen indem
wir erstmal unser Focaccia halbieren und
sich das schon schneidet ne meine Hände
werden auch so richtig ölig wenn ich das
ganze gerade so fixiere
richtig schön mit diesem gelben Mail
samura ist das glaube ich ne hammer ich
mache unsere Pfanne mal an geh mal ein
bisschen Öl hinzu Öl und so die
absoluten Klassiker Salz Pfeffer sind
wir auf die letzten Male nicht im Budget
enthalten und dann nehmen wir unsere
Focaccia die hat vielleicht 150 gekostet
damit den winzigen Teil vom Frühstück
aus aber ist natürlich absolut wichtig
ich stelle einfach mal dieses Glas auf
damit das Ganze ein bisschen beschwert
wird während ich jetzt hier so Tomaten
nehme San Marzano Tomaten das das ist
der Punkt so Leute wir haben jetzt
wirklich ein sehr üppiges Budget zur
Verfügung San marzahnautomaten bei der 1
Euro Challenge ich hätte allein nicht
mal an das Wort denken können uns ja
wirklich so hoch gekämpft ja wir haben
erstmal die die Challenges gemacht und
jetzt können wir so kreativ werden und
wir haben uns auch die Kommentare zu
Herzen genommen ja viele Leute haben
nämlich geschrieben hey Leute wir finden
es schade wenn jetzt nur noch außer Haus
gegessen wird dementsprechend heute wird
auch zweimal gekocht wieder innerhalb
des Budgets ich finde es aber trotzdem
nicht richtig oder
hier geht so viel flöten wenn wir gar
nicht außer Haus essen gehen weil ich
meine das ist ja gerade das was einem
ermöglicht wird und ich meine mir die
Banknoten weiter durchgehen kommen ja
dann 100 € 200 € 500 € mal gucken ob ich
das ganze so mache aber gesetz dem Fall
dass ich es mache wäre es glaube ich
wirklich schwer damit Normalsterblichen
Lebensmitteln irgendwas zu kochen
schneiden die Tomaten schön dünn so dass
wir sie gleich auf unsere Focaccia legen
können Schneid die extra der Länge nach
damit man weiß wenn man ist ich esse
gerade ist
gute Qualität die schmeckt direkt mit
dem Salz so herzhaft so 50 € sind
natürlich auch schon echt viel ne also
50 € und das ist auch so ermöglichen
einem eigentlich schon so ein
kulinarischen Highlighter Tag so weil
der ist schon für 50 € am Tag 1500 €,
wenn man so jeden Tag essen würde im
Monat nur für Essen
es macht garantiert keine Frage wenn man
einfach richtig gut essen will schon
auch Sinn Geld dafür auszugeben aber ich
glaube wir haben in der Vergangenheit
auch schon gezeigt dass es nicht immer
so sein muss so wir können auch mit
weniger geldhaushalten und krasse geile
Sachen essen aber das ist halt einfach
wunderschön
das wird noch fluffiger gerade durch das
Warm machen das ist richtig richtig geil
und unsere parketta werfen wir nicht
einfach so drauf sondern rösten ein
wenig in der Pfanne an einfach um noch
mehr Fett rausholen Aroma bekommen
let's go das reicht schon wir wollen nur
so ein bisschen Wärme bisschen
Temperatur reingeben wir machen
italienische Küche Spanisch hallo liebe
Öl ein Bett aus Rucola ganz ganz ganz
frisch richtig geil so wunderschön da
drauf
üppig San marsano Tomaten wow das ist
ich glaube so das hat so viel Gehalt
wahrscheinlich brauchen wir gar nicht
viel mehr essen als das italienische
markenbüffelmozzarella über 1 € direkt
unsere 1 € Challenge schon mal nicht
zugelassen sowas Schneide jetzt mal
klein ihr werdet jetzt wahrscheinlich
denken Boy macht's euch übelst leicht ja
machen wir auch aber wir machen es uns
übelst lecker ja also gar keine Frage
ich habe keine Schuldgefühle wenn ich
dieses Essen mache boah jetzt mal mit
ein bisschen Pfeffer dran unsere
Büffelmozzarella Balsamico Essig
jetzt noch mal vollgesogen mit dem
parketta Fett geben wir das oben drauf
und die Soft das oben ist oh das ist
eine doppelte Portion also du musst mir
wirklich helfen
unser Frühstück holy Moly eine Sache
fehlt uns aber noch natürlich müssen wir
auch was trinken vielleicht schon die
Orangen gesehen ich mache jetzt noch
einen frischen Orangensaft und dann
genießen wir das aber zu 100%. pochetta
Rucola Büffelmozzarella rosmarinfocaccia
San marsano Tomaten bisschen Olivenöl
bisschen Balsamico ich sag nichts
anderes ich muss nämlich auch nichts
anderes sagen guckt euch das an guckt
euch an wie saftig das ist
das leckerste sein was ich sehr jüngeren
Vergangenheit gemacht habe das sind die
besten eines Mannes der Hunger das Ding
ist hätte auch ein Restaurant gehen
können oder das so wie es ist hätte ich
nirgends investiert die Arbeit auch wenn
ihr irgendwann mal extrem reich seid
fluffiges Brot Rucola gibt vor allem
auch Crunch weil das war echt ja schnell
durch aber der Rucola oder der bleibt
ist wirklich himmlisch Leute dass das
nicht schlecht schmeckt war ja glasklar
aber wie gut es schmeckt hätte ich nicht
gedacht gerade so die Ränder vom
Focaccia sind noch so richtig schön
knusprig und so der Orangensaft wirklich
Turbo frisch aber mir fällt gerade auf
habe ich noch gar nicht gesagt wie teuer
das ganze ist warte mal wie teuer war es
noch mal es ist überhaupt kein Problem
das herauszufinden ich nutze nämlich
seit kurzem finanzguru die Jungs und
Mädels von finanzguru haben nämlich
meine Budget Videos gesehen und haben
gesagt hey Max wenn zum Budgetplanung
geht sind wir die besten finanzgure
hilft dir nämlich dabei einen Überblick
über deine Ausgaben zu behalten über
deine Fixkosten über deine
Lebensmittelkosten freizeitausgaben und
deine Verträge du musst dir nur die App
herunter und dein Konto mit der App
verknüpfen und dann ist auch ganz egal
ob Girokonto Kreditkarte dann
Aktiendepot oder Krypto Wallet sogar
PayPal funktioniert alles lässt sich
ganz einfach über ein paar Klicks
einfügen so könnt ihr schauen ob ihr
vielleicht weniger für Lebensmittel
ausgeben solltet weniger essen gehen
solltet oder mehr Sparpotenzial habt
habt ihr euer Konto verbunden habt ihr
eine Übersicht über alle Verträge und
Ausgaben bei mir war es so dass ich
erstmal verstanden habe an wenig
eigentlich alles Geld bezahlt gibt das
ein oder andere Abo was ich auf jeden
Fall kündigen kann und ob ihr vielleicht
auch ein paar unnötige Abos habt oder
vielleicht einfach besser mit eurem
geldwirtschaften könnt könnt ihr
herausfinden indem ihr euch die
finanzgure App ladet die ist komplett
kostenfrei und das beste ist mit dem
Code max 3 erhaltet ihr drei Monate
finanzguru plus kostenlos so könnt ihr
das ganze testen und wenn es euch nicht
gefällt auch jederzeit wieder beenden
und das Gute an finanzguru Plus ist dass
du immer eine Übersicht hast wie viel
Geld du noch ausgeben kannst ohne ins
Minus zu gelangen man kann unter anderem
smarte Budgets festlegen so wie ich
heute mit meinen 50 € getan habe und so
kann ich auch sehen dass ich genau 11,
71 ausgegeben habt für unser Frühstück
wundert euch nicht über die andere
Zahlung die ist fürs Abendessen dafür
habe ich auch schon eingekauft aber das
verrate ich euch erst später so konnte
ich meine Ausgaben heute perfekt
analysieren konnte im Budgetrahmen von
50 Euro bleiben und du kannst das auch
deshalb bleibt dir die App finanzguru
runter erster Link in der Beschreibung
und vergiss nicht meinen Code max 3
wir sind in einem Restaurant das ist auf
meinem Kanal nichts unübliches aber zum
ersten Mal im Rahmen von diesem Budget
challenges sitzen wir in einem
Restaurant wir hatten schon außer Haus
ein zweimal was gekauft jetzt sitzen wir
hier lassen uns verwöhnen aber das hat
auch einen bestimmten Grund denn
hier gibt es ein Mittagsangebot wir sind
bei einem indischen Restaurant hier in
Köln auf der Aachener Straße und ich
habe mir gerade schon ein bisschen was
zusammengestellt ich werde an nichts
sparen Vorspeise Hauptspeise Getränk
glaube ich gebe so um die 15 € aus damit
ich fürs Abendessen noch was übrig habe
aber das was mir ausgewählt habe kann
sie auf jeden Fall sehen lassen wir
bestellen jetzt mal und dann zeige ich
euch wir haben Roti für 2,50 € Reis und
Butter chicken für 9 Euro und ein Mango
Lassi für 4 €. da habe ich mir was
gegönnt Leute aber ich sage euch ehrlich
fühlt sich so eiskalt an ich habe die
ganze Zeit gewartet bis alles da war
sehr sehr lecker sehr sehr lecker ich
nehme jetzt hier ein bisschen von
unserem Reis ich habe wirklich die
indische Küche von den verbreiteten weit
verbreiteten bei uns mit am wenigsten
gegessen die hat man noch so ein
bisschen ausgelassen bisher ne haben wir
noch nicht viel von gekostet aber ich
habe überhaupt keine Vorbehalte oder
irgendwas sondern ich freue mich auch
sehr daraus mal hier so obendrauf ist
auch typisch indisch was man so separate
Teller bekommen dass ich das dann selbst
auf einem leeren Teller einrichten
zumindest bei den indischen Restaurants
die ich hier so kenne also wir haben uns
entschieden nur essen zu gehen wenn wir
einen Menü haben wo wir ein bisschen
sparen können weil ich wollte so eine
Vielfalt zeigen aber trotzdem halt nicht
mein gesamtes Budget verbraten zum Essen
gehen 15,50 € wenn ich mich nicht
verrechnet habe sind wir ziemlich gut
dabei fürs Mittagessen und trotzdem
bisschen so mit Köpfchen gehandelt
normalerweise das Butter chicken alleine
15,50 € alleine 15 auf 50 im Mittagsmenü
9 Euro
super lecker das hat so eine richtig so
eine starke Süße Butter chicken
kaut sich auch wie Butter also super
zartbreies Reis aber leckerer Reis boah
das ist auch wieder so eine üppige
Portion ich habe auch hier wirst du
wieder deine Diät brechen müssen und
diese gewürzkombination und so ist
eigentlich schade dass wir so selten
indisch essen gehen
der lass sie es aber Endstufe also der
ist so lecker geil auf jeden Fall sein
Geld wert der bisschen rechnen kann weiß
dass wir jetzt noch den Großteil oder
den größten Anteil von unserem Budget
fürs Abendessen übrig haben deshalb wird
es etwas ganz Besonderes etwas sehr
leckeres geben wir waren vorhin schon
Einkaufen wir genießen das ganze jetzt
erstmal ich bin noch nicht alleine hier
lassen Sie uns jetzt schmecken und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder
[Musik]
das alles für 15 Euro 50 kann sich auf
jeden Fall sehen lassen glaube ich
brauche jetzt erstmal eine Weile bis ich
wieder zu Abendessen kann dass es mehr
als genug gewesen aber zu dritt haben
wir zwei Gerichte dort gegessen deshalb
flavour of India mal vorbeischauen sehr
sehr gut gewesen Aachener Straße und
jetzt werde ich mich wieder selbst an
den Herd bzw an den Grill man merkt auf
jeden Fall wir konnten uns heute richtig
was gönnen denn wir haben einen
Thunfischsteak bekommen innerhalb von
unserem Budget dazu gibt es Couscous
dazu gibt es Grillgemüse es wird richtig
lecker und zuallererst einmal hier unser
Wasser
bitte das auf das Couscous aber das wird
nur Sättigungsbeilage während das ganze
noch ein bisschen Hitze hat machen wir
den Deckel drauf lassen das einfach für
5 Minuten ziehen ein wunderschönes
Thunfischsteak frisch gekauft heute
morgen
gelbe Zucchini die sind doppelt so teuer
wie grün aber heute geht's das Gemüse
schneide ich jetzt einfach mal klein
werden wir ganz einfach auf dem Grill
schmeißen dann so schönes Grillgemüse
bisschen grob geschnitten daraus
zubereiten wie nennt man das Ding hier
Eric eric hat gesagt sie schmeckt
doppelt so gut aber die gibt's
hauptsächlich nur in Italien
italienische Aubergine wir haben gerade
nachgeschaut diese Aubergine
unterscheidet sich von der in
Anführungszeichen normalen Aubergine
dadurch dass sie ein dichteres
kompakteres Fruchtfleisch hat und
weniger Samen wir nehmen
[Musik]
zu unserem Couscous machen wir noch eine
Joghurt mit Minze und Gurke so schneide
ich einfach eine Gurke schneiden wir
haben extra eine kleine geholt für die
günstiger ist mir nicht mehr brauchen
die schneide ich jetzt einfach in
Streifen dazu zupfe ich noch ein
bisschen Minze und das aromatisiert so
ein Joghurt so krass ein bisschen Salz
Pfeffer dazu man ja man wollte noch ein
bisschen Knoblauch ich glaube dafür
haben wir aber kein Budget mehr sie
hatten am Anfang echt lange überlegt was
wir so kochen sollen so wie kriegen wir
das hin den Rahmen irgendwie möglich
sinnvoll zu nutzen aber dann einfach das
gemacht worauf wir Lust hatten weil das
ist eigentlich das besonderste was uns
dieser Rahmen erlaubt dass wir einfach
kochen worauf wir Bock haben unsere
endgültige Rechnung inklusive
Mehrwertsteuer lag bei 20 € 5 das heißt
wenn ich nicht komplett falsch liege
haben wir alles bis auf 14 Cent oder so
ausgegeben auf jeden Fall haben wir das
Budget wieder sehr sehr gut ausgereizt
somit ist unser Dip fertig das
Grillgemüse ist jetzt auch fertig
Couscous ist durchgezogen das heißt wir
schmeißen jetzt nur noch das
Thunfischsteak auf den Grill und dann
können wir anrichten
[Musik]
also 14 Euro Thunfischsteak 2 Euro
kurskost 50 Cent Limette 99 Cent Minze
99 Cent Sprudelwasser zu Erfrischung
[Musik]
wirklich sehr erfrischend wir sehen auf
jeden Fall bunt es ist hübsch es ist
lecker bzw das sehen wir jetzt gleich
erst wenn ich probiere aber ich finde es
sieht alles mega gut aus diese Zucchini
hier schöne röste darum ungeschlagen das
auf dem Grill zuzubereiten schauen wir
mal wie das Thunfischsteak geworden ist
ich finde die Kruste spricht für sich
wow so muss es sein innen drin noch
halbro
was krass eigentlich gar nicht kauen du
hast so ein leichten crisp draußen von
der Kruste und innen drin ist wirklich
so das schon fast so als würde so wie
bei vagio so fett in deinem Mund
zerlaufen richtig richtig gut komplett
der Kontrast von dieser knusprigen
Kruste zum saftigen inneren man weiß
dass kann nicht ganz billig sein so weil
das einfach so krass schmeckt oder das
ist einfach was ganz feines dann auf
unser Couscous
Joghurt Minze
der kühle Joghurt mit dieser Minznote
und Couscous das passt einfach perfekt
zusammen und dann dieses milde so sowohl
Couscous und auch Joghurt diese
kräftigen röste Aromen am Gemüse und am
Thunfisch aber ich finde was wir heute
gegessen haben kann sich wirklich sehen
lassen man könnte no joke ich glaube der
ein oder andere würde denken dass das so
ein Medium rares Steak ist einfach
soweit man kommt man könnte denken so
das ist gar kein Thunfisch so ein
richtig perfekt ist Sommeressen und so
dass ich auch meinen Sommertag heute
ausklingen ich glaube ich musste auch im
Vorfeld niemandem sagen dass man für 50
€ sehr gut essen kann wie gut haben wir
heute gesehen es ist schon fast so dass
ich mir nicht mehr vorstellen könnte
aber es gibt ja noch größere Geldschein
glaube ich muss wirklich kreativ werden
wenn wir das ganze noch machen sollten
mit 100 € schreibt mal in die Kommentare
ob ihr Bock darauf habt hier ist ein für
dich vorgeschlagenes Video nur für dich
deshalb also hier guck sie an wenn Du
Lust drauf hast beim nächsten Video
wieder ciao
[Musik]